de mémoire on n'a jamais vu une telle
somme pour ce genre de subventions
jamais et on n'a toujours pas compris
les contreparties à l'argent public qui
allaient être utilisés pour rénover ce
qui au final et sa maison à elle puisque
c'est bien son nom et malade il avait
elle avait des projets donc pour faire
des choses dans la production c'est ça
oui c'est pour sa maison de production
oui c'est ça exactement c'est ça mais
non c'est une maison qui sera à son nom
qui va être pendant 15 ans l'usufruit de
sa société de production mais en réalité
personne n'a clairement compris et c'est
pour ça que la presse s'est saisi de la
sphère d'accord personne n'a compris les
contreparties mais pourquoi une telle
somme lui était accordé donc elle jamais
de ces de ces montants là pour des
rénovations énergétiques de mémoire
jamais quand on dit que qu'elle a reçu
44 % du montant alors qu'elle pouvait
aller jusqu'à 70% ça vous dit que non
c'est pas vrai je dis que c'est étonnant
qu'il ait une telle somme qui était
utilisé pour ce pour un pour ça et nous
ce qui nous a vraiment indigné c'est
d'ailleurs elle le dit elle renonce à
cet argent parce qu'elle peut faire
autrement et donc en réaliser cet argent
n'a pas besoin alors qu'elles en ont
besoin d'argent et bien je
lisais c'est de l'argent puis pas ce
doit être réalisé pour les habitants et
les habitants de la région mais auront
la transition énergétique des habitants
et des habitants de la région mais ce
qu'elle a dit elle a dit qu'elle avait
un projet de transition énergétique
bernard montiel non elle elle avait le
droit légitime c'est sa maison de
production et elle devait payer un loyer
tous les mois elle a bien dit elle était
très clair là dessus maintenant le
relance us à la suite à la polémique
mais c'est dommage de la torre gilles
verdez elle était obligée de renoncer ça
s'appelle le domaine des belles âmes ça
a été acheté un million 3 et n'oublions
pas que la somme ces 44 % du montant des
études 117 1000 euros ça veut dire que
c'est des études à plus de 250000 euros
quelle propriété nécessite des études
comme ça donc c'était très opaque il y
avait deux personnes qui allaient
travailler il ya 5000 mètres carrés de
jardin à rénover c'était tellement
opaques elle ne pouvait pas résister à
ça déjà je ne sais pas pourquoi ça a été
votée mais c'était impossible de garder
cette subvention pas été bottées je
salue le fait qu'elle soit qu'elles
aient renoncé à cette surenchère c'était
vraiment la bonne wiision en réalité au
cas c'est une victoire pour nous les
écologistes parce que c'est vraiment une
politique bling bling en réalité c'est
une politique bling bling pour des gens
qui n'ont pas besoin on a 40% de
passoires thermiques dans notre région
on a des lycées qui sont vétustes et
l'argent dans la transition énergétique
et doit être mis pour les gens qui en
ont vraiment besoin après elle vous
rénovez elle a parlé de démonstrateurs
pédagogique seulement vous parler mais
c'est un match qui a coûté plus d'un
million d'euros et celle à qui ça va
servir comme exemple
ça sert uniquement à des gens et ce qui
se passe dans la région paca ça sert
uniquement à des gens extrêmement riche
et ça ne permettra pas aux particuliers
je pense par exemple aux gens qui se
retrouvent dans ces passoires thermiques
qui ont sûrement encore cet hiver devoir
renoncer à se chauffer ou mal se
chauffer ça ne leur permettra absolument
pas d'entamer la rénovation thermique la
rénovation énergétique par mangou tison
de besoin non mais c'est soit il soit
l'oea droit et voilà contribuer à
améliorer voilà c'est un fait mais
apparemment c'est fait c'est une bourse
ou consommer pourquoi est-ce que ça vous
gêne 6 6 passes et ray minutes et c'est
inutile et totalement non mais moi
j'aime pas les gars mais aussi légal ou
pas du tout passé ça régale le fait que
ce soit quelqu'un de connu qui mais qui
bénéficie de subventions bon voilà nous
avons demandé le retrait nous avons
demandé le retrait de la subvention pour
que l'argent public si
elles sont toutes les balles vont
demander le retrait nous avons demandé
leur retrait de la subvention à renaud
muselier qui s'apprêtait à lui accorder
qui est le président de la région cela
on l'a vu poser avec lui d'ailleurs nous
n'avons rien comme me contre madame le
marchand nous c'est nous avons
interpellé la région d'accord je
rappelle que les écologistes sont
retirés face au danger du rassemblement
national aux dernières élections
régionales et c'est sûrement pas pour
que l'argent public soit utilisé cette
façon donc oui oui bon gars devant moi
je trouve ça trop facile de parler de
dire c'est légal déjà parce que ça n'a
pas été une décision de justice en fait
c'est renaud muselier qui a décidé donc
c'est une décision qui est politique est
ce que vous dites est très juste elle en
a les moyens alors que d'autres
personnes juste cet hiver là et c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut réaliser
certaines personnes crève de froid quoi
et cet argent là on a si on avait de
l'argent en illimité ok pas de problème
mais là c'est pas le cas donc ça brive
et dans la formation que cet argent va
évidemment étudié c'est ça le problème
j'espère bien après la polémique qui
s'est tapé je crois bien qu'il mette les
117 1000 pour les aider des familles qui
sont en difficulté mais surtout derrière
ils sont très proches ils sont très amis
en politique il ya quand même une
certaine posture à avoir de a à z ça
tient pas cette affaire de a à z ça
tient pas doivent d'ailleurs ce qu'a
dénoncé marsactu c'est que
tout est au conditionnel ça pourrait
servir pour une émission est en fête et
puis il ya eu plein de versions
différentes qui ont été données par
madame le marchand ou par renaud
muselier le président de la région paca
donc enfin en réalité on n'arrive
toujours pas à comprendre pour quelles
raisons cet argent devait être lui être
donnée donc vous dites que dans son
bureau tout seul renaud muselier a dit
je vais donner cette aide à madame le
marchand comme ça en tête de gondole
médiatique comme ça de la rénovation et
je dis que je soulève la question et
c'est pour cette dame on est le retrait
de la subvention c'est pour ça que
l'après leur en est l'ambassadrice de la
ola
c'est parce que on attaque on a pas on à
paris salle et elle est rémunérée pour
être ambassadrice de la région alors
normalement les rires oui oui elle est
rémunérée être en baisse à 10
ambassadrices de la région mais les
journalistes n'arrivent pas à savoir
combien mais ça veut dire qu'on bat sa
nourrice de la région paca ça ne veut
rien dire series et non mais ça n'est
rien
rice la promotion et
la promotion de la région d'accord je
récite des versets du lycée je mange un
pan bagnat ouais c'est comme en aval et
gratuit elle vient d'être engagé donc
pour l'instant et aucune action concrète
les journalistes êtes journaliste jean
cras encore en train de se demander
combien les rémunérés et en faites vous
là c'est pourquoi madame côte au conseil
pouvait pas demander les chiffres ya pas
d enquête j'ai une valeur qu'on fait
puisque je fais partie des gens qui se
sont retirés pour empêcher voilà
ça n'a rien à voir c'est autre chose
mais vous puisque vous êtes là dans la
région paca vous auriez pu demander si
non mais bon en tout cas si rémunérés
oui donc par rapport à ça triste ça ne
s'est pas partie de ce qui est dit pour
l'instant ça sera accessible plus tard
puisqu'il s'agit il s'agit de ce qui
rend dans le plan média donc c'est
uniquement quand le but en tout cas là
elle a bien fait de réagir autrement
franchement c'est important qu'elle le
fasse pas